les gens Québécois ne sont pas racistes
ce n'était pas mon intention et pour le
blessures que j'ai faisais avec mes mots
je m'excuse sincèrement je pense que ça
démontre à quel point c'est une personne
sensible qui est ouvert ou
préoccupations des autres qui veut
justement bâtir des ponts et les la
bonne personne pour le faire monsieur
Trudeau persiste à défendre une mauvaise
décision il va vivre avec cette décision
là je pense que tout était dit
les excuses et une partie des réactions
cette semaine la nomination de Mira el
ghaouabi qui a dominé l'actualité
Ottawa et à Québec est-ce que le
gouvernement Trudeau a sous-estimé la
réaction que cette annonce à avoir
voyons voir ce qu'on pense mais fidèles
collaborateurs
de midi info et si première et
chroniqueur au Toronto Star et magazine
de l'actualité et Michel CEG est un
hélice politique à La Presse et
Radio-Canada bonjour à vous trois
bonjour Chantal est-ce qu'on avait
sous-estimé ce qui s'est passé la
réaction que ça allait susciter ce qu'on
avait mal vérifié le passé de Madame
qu'est-ce qu'on comprend de ce qui est
arrivé cette semaine
que vous êtes très généreux avec
sous-estimé parce que ça voudrait dire
qu'on s'est rendu compte de ce qu'on
faisait et normalement vous le savez
comme moi quand on nomme quelqu'un qui
qu'on sait quelque part il va y avoir un
os on prépare ses réponses en
conséquence et on prépare les gens les
plus susceptibles de se faire interroger
en conséquence
avait été préparé aux gens de bagages
que que madame a porté à son rôle
s'intéressait pas beaucoup
ça réaction plutôt viscérale elle est
pas du tout dans ce sens-là l'impression
que ça donne c'est un on a pas fait de
vérifications à fond moi je fais partie
des gens qui ont tendance à croire que
Justin Trudeau oui était au courant de
l'espèce de chronique mal ficelé qui où
on se servait à corps d'un sondage pour
prétendre que tous ceux qui appuient la
loi 21 sont islamophobes je pense qu'il
était au courant de ça je suis pas
convaincu qu'il était au courant du
tweet où elle disait moi ça me fait
vomir quand on dit que les Canadiens
français ont été maltraités opprimés ou
qui ont soumis ont été sujet de la
discrimination sous le règne britannique
j'ai l'impression je veux croire que
Monsieur Trudeau vous avez connu cette
citation là ce serait dit comme
n'importe lequel entre nous remplaçons
canadien français par autochtone est-ce
qu'on engagerait quelqu'un comme ça même
après des excuses je la réponse non
processus de validation les politiques
sont familiales avec ça là en campagne
électorale le candidat qui n'a aucune
chance d'être élu on valide son passé
juste au camp comment est-ce qu'on a
fait pour se rendre là
on a un échappe aussi dans les électro
quand même il y a plus de validation
d'un coup exact il y a le 338 dans des
circonscriptions parfois beaucoup
d'attention dans ce cas si c'est un
poste rémunéré plus de 160 000 dollars
par les Denis publics qui à
l'inévitablement avoir un profil plus
élevé je suis assez d'accord avec
Chantal je pense qu'on savait cette
espèce de chronique dans le Ottawa
synthéisme mais qu'on n'a pas vérifié
beaucoup plus loin les propos de cette
dame là alors là peut-être jugée que
c'est on était capable de vivre avec la
l'inverse autour de sa lettre dans la
Ottawa c'était zen à l'époque le reste
c'est un peu difficile de vivre avec ça
c'est à dire que pour Justin Trudeau on
est capable de vivre avec le Parti
conservateur qui aime pas cette
nomination le Bloc québécois assez
précisé par québécois va au gouvernement
le goût ça fait un peu grincer des dames
mais on était capable de vivre avec
partie libérale du Québec déjà ça fait
un peu plus mal le pour que le Parti
libéral du Québec demande cette
démission et ce qui a causé le plus de
remous c'est à l'intérieur même du
caucus de Justin Trudeau son cocus du
Québec et tu es pas content de cette
nomination là c'est une controverse dont
ce serait bien passé donc quand à
l'interne on chauffe les oreilles du
Premier ministre son cabinet parce que
là on en a clairement échappé une ça
fait en sorte que j'étais Trudeau sort
deux fois plus tôt qu'une sur un sujet
relativement mineur ça reste devant les
journalistes comment ça faire de la
pédagogie sur la Révolution tranquille
québécoise la différence entre la
laïcité et tout ça c'est très instructif
ça mais ça voulait aussi dire que le
premier ministre
n'était pas dans une très bonne position
quand on est rendu là est-ce que est-ce
que Michel ça pose un problème en sens
où est-ce que c'est le genre de dommage
qui peut durer sur monsieur Trudeau sur
la marque libérale où ce n'est pas en
campagne électorale encore mais on s'en
va vers quelque chose à un moment donné
oui et surtout de la marque libérale sur
la façon dont ils sont capables de faire
fonctionner le gouvernement ça pose des
sérieux question là aussi des gens qui
étaient pas capables de donner des
passeports là maintenant on est rendu au
chèque d'assurance voici des gens qui
sont pas capables de faire marcher le
Parlement de journée sur deux et il y a
vraiment
c'était compréhensible ça prend des
millisecondes à Google pour trouver tout
ce qu'on a reprochait à cette dame là et
ça a été fait au bureau du premier
ministre alors les amendements sur la
loi vendredi sur des choses comme ça à
un moment donné sacré une masse critique
de d'actions qui ont été manqués et de
gens qui vont dire
qui c'est qui gouverne là est-ce que ces
gens-là sont compétents à gouvernés
qu'est-ce qui se passe au bureau du
premier ministre au gouvernement libéral
et c'est la cohérence
il y a un double problème ça fait des
mois et c'est encore plus le cas à la
lumière du plus récent sondage avec eux
qui donnait quand même plus que 6 points
d'avance aux parties conservateur au
National et en passant c'est un sondage
qui couvre pas la tempête qui s'est
abattue au Québec cette semaine mais
depuis des mois c'est le Québec qui
garde les libéraux à flots dans les
intentions de vote si Monsieur Trudeau
ne se maintenait pas comme il se
maintient au Québec il serait encore
plus loin dans la course au pouvoir dans
les intentions de vote cette tempête ici
non seulement c'est abattue au Québec
mais c'est la plus grosse tempête qui
s'est abattue sur le gouvernement Justin
Trudeau depuis qu'il est premier
ministre au Québec parce que sensei la
banane ici ça s'est pas passé exactement
de la même façon et là on vient d'aller
jouer exactement dans cette table
premier problème deuxième problème dans
ce sondage dévastateur de la Bacchus ont
demandé aux gens pensez-vous que le
gouvernement suffisamment du coût de la
vie
75% disent non ce que ça donne comme
impression une semaine passée à jouer du
violon sur le front de l'islamophobie
c'est que l'opposition raison que je
gouvernement s'occupe pas de ce qu'on
appelle entre guillemets des vrais
affaires et qui s'occupe de toutes
sortes de choses qui sont
inévitablesment dans la marge pour la
face majorité des électeurs puis là ça
vient consolider le narratif le message
des conservateurs de l'autre côté de la
chambre un jour rapidement Michel puis
ensuite Alex sur la pertinence du poste
maintenant ça fait quoi à la dame parce
que là on a pas l'impression de vouloir
le larguer il y a pas de signaux du côté
du gouvernement qui nous dit on va on va
la laisser aller tranquille on va rester
en poste en tout cas monsieur Trudeau le
3 fois plutôt qu'une qu'est-ce que ça
dans quelle situation sur la place
Michel
il va avoir un déficit de crédibilité au
Québec au minimum ce qui fait que
lorsqu'elle va parler personne ne va
l'écouter donc effectivement
complètement inefficace vous savez il
existe un poste de représentant du
Canada pour la lutte contre
l'antisémitisme on l'oublie parfois mais
c'est
que ce poste là personne n'a remis en
question la pertinence du poste lorsque
Monsieur Kotler a été nommé
également
on l'entend pas beaucoup c'est un poste
plutôt symbolique connoryphique c'est
pas quelqu'un qui est sur toute les
tribunes alors madame el ghaouabi elle
est probablement pas occupée beaucoup
plus de place que Monsieur katler donc
c'est pas comme si soudainement on
venait de perdre une voix critique là
pour la lutte contre l'islamophobie
n’empêche que ce poste là avait
peut-être raison d'être créé il y a bel
et bien des gens qui détestent l'islam
qui détestent les musulmans au Canada et
qui peut-être effectivement reconstruire
des ponts étaient utiles mais d'avoir
une personne dans un poste si elle ne
sert à rien en fait automatiquement le
poste devient utile et peut-être que
donc le gouvernement Trudeau fait
exactement le contraire de ce qui aurait
souhaité il y aurait souhaité pouvoir
montrer qu'il lutte contre
l'islamophobie à la laisser en place il
fait surtout la démonstration qui a peur
des contrecoups politiques notamment au
Canada anglais beaucoup plus que de se
préoccuper de la véritable lutte contre
je vous vois réagir rapidement ouais
mais quelque part je suis pas convaincu
moi qu'en regardant les statistiques on
peut conclure qu'avoir dont je reconnais
toutes les qualités d'autre part comme
représentant l'antisémitisme ça a eu le
moindre impact sur l'antisémitisme et
j'attends encore qu'on me fasse la
démonstration que de nommer une
représentante spéciale sur
l'islamophobie ça va avoir un impact
positif sans égal à personne davantage
que le fait que le maire de Calgary a
été musulman ou qu'il y a des ministres
qui représentent ce courant là autour de
la table de Monsieur Trudeau
on va voir la suite des choses là-dessus
je vais vous entendre rapidement il nous
reste 4 minutes sur Mackenzie cette
semaine les contrats des films de
consultants dans la loupe d'un comité
entre autres parce que Dominique Burton
qu'on connaît comme l'ancien patron de
mécanisier aussi ancienne ambassadeur du
Canada en Chine conseiller financier
pour deux gouvernements qui étaient là
qu'est-ce que vous avez retenu Michel de
ce de ce témoignage de ce qu'on en a
ressorti ou de ce qu'on a tenté d'en
faire ressortir des parties de position
comme c'est le mauvais élève si vous
voulez des films de consultants qui est
dénoncés un peu partout en France et
partout
a fait une relativement bonne job de
dire hey je prends un ami du saint
Trudeau on va pas la peine chanson et le
nombre de contrats mécanis est
relativement faible mais ce que les
parties de position ont trouvé et dans
lesquelles ils vont mordre je pense
beaucoup plus ardemment dans les
prochaines semaines c'est tous les
délais qui est KPMG tous les autres
consultants qui eux ont un énorme énorme
contrat avec le gouvernement et qui
dédoublent très souvent le travail que
devrait faire la fonction publique alors
ça c'est peut-être plus porteur pour des
parties de position que Mackenzie même
si Mackenzie il bad boy actuellement de
ces films là
sauf que ce que le Parti conservateur
vouliez trouver c'était du copinage et
il y a pas eu d'eau à son moulin
le gouvernement
donc c'est pas une telle intéressante
pour le Parti conservateur le NPD est
totalement intéressant entre autres à
cause de sa relation avec les grandes
centrales syndicales de la Fonction
publique qui aime pas le recours au
consultant le Bloc québécois s'intéresse
plus à Mackenzie à cause des conseils de
Dominique Barton sur l'immigration alors
je vous dirais que dans tout ça je
reconnais très positif probablement et
que ça risque de finir en shoad bouquin
avec
Chantal faisait allusion le me reste
qu'on détende ça l'ensemble des films de
consultants est-ce que c'est là que ça
va s'en aller ou c'est vraiment
mécanique et dans l'œil de la tempête
c'était le meilleur moment de ce comité
parlementaire là c'est qu'à la NPD
déposé le motion pour élargir l'étude
dans le comité à d'autres firmes de
consultants parce que pour le reste
sur la comparution comme telle le
Dominique baril moi j'ai trouvé que les
députés de l'opposition étaient assez
gênant en réalité ça faisait très petite
politique les questions du Parti
conservateur sur ce que vous connaissez
Trudeau ce que vous avez sur le numéro
de cellulaire le Bloc québécois qui
était toutes sortes de chiffres un peu
mais là un peu complexe sur
l'immigration on a essayé de marquer des
points politiques pour tous les partis
en étage chaque fois un peu à côté de la
traque Dominique Barton a eu le beau jeu
de paraître comme celui qui est dans le
fond avec rien à se rapprocher alors
vivement qu'on s'intéresse à l'ensemble
de l'oeuvre des films de consulta plutôt
qu'un mécaniser parce que mettons que la
première journée nous a pas paru
particulièrement
enrichissante sur le sursaut plan là
c'est vraiment pas terminé d'ailleurs la
vérificatrice générale se penche aussi
sur sur les contrats accordés voir s'il
y a une valeur réelle pour l'appareil
public là-dessus c'est tout le temps
reste Alexandre Michel Mercier
infiniment la semaine prochaine
au revoir